BUT FIRST, STARBUCKS AND BLACK
AND WHITE.
THAT IS THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT
"ANGLE" ."
♪ ♪
NEVER HAS A REQUEST TO USE THE
BATHROOM CAUSED SO MUCH HAVOC.
LAST WEEK, TWO BLACK MEN WERE
AWAITING A MEETING AT A
STARBUCKS IN PHILLY.
THEY ASKED TO USE THE BATHROOM.
BUT THEY WERE TOLD NO.
BECAUSE IT WAS RESERVED FOR
CUSTOMERS, AND THEY HAD BOUGHT
NOTHING.
SO THEY RETURNED TO THEIR SEATS
AND BECAUSE THEY HAD PURCHASED
NOTHING, THEY WERE THEN ASKED TO
LEAVE.
THEY DIDN'T AT THE MANAGER
CALLED 911.
>> HI, I HAVE TWO GENTLEMAN AT
MY CAFE THAT ARE REFUSING TO
MAKE A PURCHASE OR LEAVE.
I'M AT THE STARBUCKS.
>> ALL RIGHT, POLICE WILL BE OUT
AS OUT AS SOON AS POSSIBLE.
>> Laura: THE TWO MEN WERE
ARRESTED BUT NOT BEFORE IT WAS
ALL CAPTURED ON A PHONE AND THEN
IT WENT VIRAL.
SOON A STARBUCKS BOYCOTT
CAMPAIGN RAGED ACROSS SOCIAL
MEDIA.
ACTIVISTS RUSHED TO THE
OFFENDING STARBUCKS STAR AND
HASHTAGS SUCH AS
#StarbucksWhileBlack STARTED
TRENDING BUYING TIME.
WITHIN A DAY, STARBUCKS HAD
APOLOGIZED.
TWO DAYS AFTER THE INCIDENT, THE
MANAGER WHO CALLED 911 WAS NO
LONGER WITH THE COMPANY AND ITS
FOUNDER, HOWARD SCHULTZ,
DESCRIBED HER THIS WAY.
>> I THINK YOU HAVE TO SAY, AND
LOOKING AT THE TAPE, THAT SHE
DEMONSTRATED HER OWN LEVEL OF
UNCONSCIOUS BIAS.
LOOKING AT THE TAPE, YOU ASK
YOURSELF WHETHER OR NOT THAT IN
FACT WAS RACIAL PROFILING.
THERE IS NO DOUBT IN MY MIND,
THE REASON THEY WERE CALLED WAS
BECAUSE THEY WERE
AFRICAN-AMERICANS.
>> Laura: THERE'S A LOT WE
STILL DON'T KNOW.
HERE ARE SOME QUESTIONS.
WAS THERE A PATTERN OF RACIAL
BIAS IN THIS PHILADELPHIA
STARBUCKS?
WERE OTHER AFRICAN-AMERICANS
TREATED UNFAIRLY THERE?
AND DO THIS PARTICULARLY
EMPLOYEE DISPLAY A PRACTICE OF
RACISM IN THE PAST?
OR WHAT YOU JUST ENFORCING
COMPANY POLICY BY DENYING THE
BATHROOM TO NONCUSTOMERS AND
TRYING TO STOP THEM LOITERING?
THAT'S NOT GOOD FOR BUSINESS.
THE CALL TO THE COPS SEEMS LIKE
OVERKILL, BUT AGAIN, WE DON'T
KNOW THE FULL STORY.
AS A STARBUCKS BASED THESE
DEMONSTRATIONS ALL OVER THE
COUNTRY, THERE WAS A RUSH TO
JUDGMENT ON THE COMPANY QUICKLY
JUMPED ON IT AND A LOT OF PEOPLE
WENT OVERBOARD.
RATHER THAN JUST APOLOGIZING AND
DISCIPLINING AND OUT OF LINE
EMPLOYEE, STARBUCKS ANNOUNCES
THAT IT WAS CLOSING 8,000 STORES
FOR ONE DAY IN MAY, AND ON THAT
DAY, THEY WILL FORCE 170,000 OF
ITS EMPLOYEES TO UNDERGO RACIAL
BIAS TRAINING.
ACCORDING TO
"THE WASHINGTON POST," THE
SESSIONS WILL INCLUDE TRAINING
IN SOMETHING YOU MIGHT NOT KNOW
OF, BUT IT'S CALLED UNCONSCIOUS
BIAS, WHERE APPARENTLY YOU ARE
UNAWARE OF YOUR INHERENT BIAS,
YOU DISPLAYED NO OVERT RACISM,
BUT YOU ARE BIASED NONETHELESS.
THE TRAINING WILL BE GUIDED BY,
WAIT FOR IT, FORMER
ATTORNEY GENERAL ERIC HOLDER!
THE NAACP, ANTIDEFAMATION LEGAL
OFFICIAL.
WHAT COULD POSSIBLY GO WRONG?
HOLDER, OF COURSE, HAS HIS OWN
HISTORY IN DISCUSSING RACE.
>> IN THINGS RACIAL, WE HAVE
ALWAYS BEEN, AND WE CONTINUE TO
BE, INTO MANY WAYS, ESSENTIALLY
A NATION OF COWARDS.
>> Laura: THAT IS HOW HE
INTRODUCED HIMSELF TO THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT WHEN HE
BECAME ATTORNEY GENERAL COME BY
THE WAY.
THIS IS THE MAN WHO WILL CONDUCT
A TRAINING ON RACE RELATIONS OF
175,000 EMPLOYEES.
THIS IS WHERE WE ARE.
ONE EMPLOYEE IN PHILADELPHIA
CALLS THE COPS ON A PAIR OF
BLACK MEN AND EMPLOYEES ACROSS
THE NATION ARE KIND OF ASSUMED
TO BE LATENT RACISTS.
STARBUCKS IS ONE OF THE MOST
LIBERAL COMPANIES IN THE WORLD.
YOU THINK BEN AND JERRY'S, HERE
ON THE LEVEL OF LEFT WING,
STARBUCKS IS UP HERE.
THEY FIRED REFUGEES WITH THE
PROTESTS AGAINST
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S POLICIES, THEY
FORCED BARISTAS TO ADDRESS RACE
RELATIONS WITH CUSTOMERS A FEW
YEARS BACK.
THEY WERE MADE TO SCRAWL THAT
RACEDTOGETHER ON COFFEE CUPS?
IF THE COFFEE CHAIN THOUGHT IT
WAS GOING TO INOCULATE HIMSELF
AGAINST LIBERAL IRE BY BEING
LEFT-LEANING, THEY WERE WRONG.